[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on va passer cette édition
avec jean des cars le biographe des
souverains et des dynasties européennes
qui publiques chez perrin la saga des
windsor de l' empire britannique
elizabeth ii a un gros livre
pas illustré on va illustrer et nous
mêmes
alors quelle est cette famille qui
compte parmi les plus grosses fortunes
du monde d'où vient-elle en quoi mérite
t'elle de nous intéresser est-elle si
fascinante qu'on le dit on va voir ça
mais commençons tout de suite par
l'image que vous avez choisi jean des
cars bah c'est justement l'image de
trois de ses représentants pourquoi
celle-ci bien parce que c'était un
document sur une situation
exceptionnelle l'année 1936 des
britanniques ont eu trois rois sur la
gauche vous avez le roi georges cinq cas
est le deuxième fils d'edouard vii qui
régnait depuis 1910 et qui meurent au
début de l'année 1936 au centre son fils
le prince héritier le prince de galles
edwards qui devient
brièvement seulement neuf fois le roi
édouard 8
pourquoi seulement neuf mois parce qu'il
abdique car il veut vivre et épouser la
femme qu'il aime la sulfureuse wallis
simpson une américaine déjà divorcé deux
fois et dont le scandale est permanent
et à droite ce qui n'était pas prévu
dans l'histoire
le roi george vi qui est donc le nouveau
souverain
fin décembre 1936 etc et le père
d'elizabeth ii berti surnommé berti et
tout le monde sait qu il était
absolument appeler car il souffrait d'un
problème d'élocution on sait très bien
qu'ils avaient du mal à s'exprimer qu'il
sera soigné par un thérapeute australien
monsieur logue qui l'aidera à faire ses
discours et qui sera le roi très
courageux de la seconde guerre mondiale
donc voilà une situation unique trois
rois l'année des trois-rois 1936 il
avait une certaine prestance à l'époque
encore on
si aujourd'hui il en août autant vous
trouvez-vous batailles sont en uniforme
ce soir des fêtes
formidable il y avait le passage de l'
empire au commonwealth
il ya de grands moments là il ya quand
même l'irlande la création de l'état
libre d'irlande pas il se passe beaucoup
de choses mais
georges 5 le grand père d'elizabeth et
de margaret a été bouleversée parce que
à son
jubilé
la foule lui a été reconnaissante parce
qu'il a été très courageux comme un
première guerre mondiale
il a aidé énormément les français lors
de la bataille de la somme
cet homme qui passait pour terne est un
a été formidable dans son rôle de
monarque constitutionnel
il faut savoir et il adorait
ses petites filles c'est lui qui assure
me mais elisabeth lilibet tu
assures non je dis bien sûr - et non pas
un prénom comme le prétend mais gagnent
aujourd'hui surnom parce que lisa bêtes
avaient du mal à 4 ans à dire elisabeth
donc lille i bet c'était plus court
alors commençons par leur nom c'est
georges 5 qui va adopter le nom de
winstorm et en 1917 et il se trouve que
les bombardiers allemands qui a ce
moment la largue les premières bombes
sur la ville de londres et qui causent à
septembre de victimes on envoie un là
c'était un otage et or le nom de famille
de la famille royale anglaise s'était
saxe cobourg gotha deux visages un nom
allemand il va falloir qu'ils en
changent il reste que c'est très très
mal portée en
1903 d'anglais à l'origine on peut dire
pour résumer que les rois d'angleterre
était d'origine allemande entre les
anneaux de saxe cobourg gotha
effectivement georges 5 qui ne passait
pas pour un génie cette idée remarquable
en 1917 de dire ce n'est pas possible et
d'expliquer aux américains qu'on se bat
contre les allemands alors que nous
avons un nom allemand dont il prend la
décision de choisir windsor ce qui est
très malin parce que c'est une
forteresse qui est aujourd'hui la plus
grande forteresse du monde toujours
habité ses mille ans d'histoire depuis
guillaume le conquérant on ne peut pas
avoir plus britannique tout bon polar du
voilà voilà forteresse de weser
certainement le château le habitait
depuis plus longtemps double mandat
absolument et qui reste si vous voulez
moi je sais pas ce que je les fais
visiter plusieurs fois 31 décembre quand
il ya personne la reine n'était pas là
mais avec la garde c'est très très
impressionnant dimension de cette
forteresse où la future elizabeth ii a
passé une partie de la guerre avec les
joyaux de la couronne cachés dans des
boîtes de biscuits et vivent les
restrictions comme la population
c'est-à-dire un oeuf le dimanche et
l'eau du bain était d'un niveau très
réduit et pas toujours chaude ouais mais
ils ont ils ont pas de mal à se priver
la famille royale britannique dans en
général les enfants même william et
harry raconte qu'enfant il n'avait pas
droit de se chauffer dans leur chambre
enfin ils ont tous vécu d enfance
épouvantable
alors disons que c'est une famille où on
aime les économies parce qu'on déteste
le gaspillage et c'est pour ça que la
reine actuelle fait partie de ces gens
et je la comprends qui fait état de la
lumière ou et à la lumière quand elle
quitte la pièce et qu'elle ne va pas y
revenir comme tous les gens qui ont vécu
la guerre et en l'occurrence quelquefois
de guerre jusqu'à une certaine
génération donc les restrictions ce
n'est pas du tout pour se faire
remarquer c'était on ne gaspille pas pu
effectivement donc le voilà georges 5
qui choisit winsor et une autre non un
qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient étudié
winsor c'est vraiment serré absolument
pas ce que ça disait tout de suite un
nom aux gens avec cette forteresse
formidable qui n'est pas très loin de de
londres où
il y alors le parc avec plusieurs
résidences en intérieur il y à la
chapelle saint georges qu'on a encore
revu récemment mariages cérémonies et
personne n'oubliera le visage de la
reine derrière son masque de deuil aux
obsèques du prince philippe dans cette
chapelle vides il y a les tombes des
souverains de la famille en a d'autres
un peu répartis dans le parc danser on
peut pas faire plus britannique
maintenant s'ils voulaient c'était une
décision très astucieuse de georges
salle georges 5 6 qui a permis
pardonnez-moi à guillaume deux petits
fils de victoria tout de même le calice
de dire mais je ne savais pas le kaiser
je ne savais pas que shakespeare avait
aussi écrit les joyeuses commères de
saxe cobourg
deux mois avant de changer de nom
georges 5 avait quand même abandonné à
son sort le hasard nicolas 2 wii dont il
était le cousin est le sosie ou avoir
ces mecs qui se ressemblent comme deux
gouttes d'eau les voilà oui et quand il
est renversant par la première
révolution la révolution de février
il demande l'asile politique aux anglais
et alors ça a été toute une histoire on
n'a jamais su on a laissé crois que
c'était premier ministre en fait ce
serait georges lot 5 qui leur ai dit non
il faut pas qu'ils viennent parce que
les anglais déjà en ont marre de la
guerre peut-être un peu marre de la
monarchie aussi c'est pas le moment de
les provoquer je pense que c'est assez
vraisemblable comme explication mais il
a eu un remords épouvantable parce
qu'après évidemment dans les bras il
s'est fait assassiner le renard nicolas
2 et dans l'effondrement des monarchies
après 1918 il est certain que le rôle
britannique n'avait pas été brillant
maintenant je peux ajouter un détail à
propos de
raspoutine il est vraisemblable que ce
sont les services secrets britanniques
qui auraient en fait exécuter et prince
philippe charles souchon tirait très mal
mais il y avait un agent parce qu'on a
retrouvé des balles anglaise est une
arme anglaise beaucoup plus tard c'était
difficile à dire parce qu'il fallait
quand même un professionnel pour se
débarrasser de raspoutine raspoutine qui
était contre la guerre qui était contre
la guerre et qui avait dit dans un
télégramme très célèbre à la clarine à
l'impératrice si ton mari se lance dans
la guerre la russie sera recouverte d'un
fleuve de sang
et oui mais on doit par dont les
français doivent reconnaître à la russie
d'avoir aidé au nom de l'alliance
franco-russe pour la bataille de la
marne éviter que paris ne tombe bien
faire 1910 à la fin de la guerre neuf
monarques européens sont détrônés pas
georges 5 il est toujours là sans doute
parce qu'il a changé de nom sans doute
aussi parce qu'il a laissé tomber son
cousin le tard
le retour à la paix pour hilla il
revient à pep de manière triomphale
georges 5 oui absolument il est très
aimée très respectée je dis bien que cet
homme paraissait terne très maniaque
organisé réglant le les pendules de ses
appartements détestant les gens en
retard et cetera apparemment je dirais
pas un génie mais du bon sens et
courageux comme à la guerre y compris en
venant en france
il tend beaucoup plus intéressant que la
façade ne la laissez le supposer alors
il était donc allemand les souverains
d'angleterre depuis georges premier en
1714 que les lecteurs de manoeuvre qui
vient est en fait vous dites qu'ils ont
tous un accent allemand george 5 avait
encore un accent allemand qu'il a
dissimulé un accent aidera demande
comment l'expliquez-vous commencer je
pense que génétiquement ils ne pouvaient
pas du thé et ça ça faisait un petit peu
désordre ans a donné lieu à des gags à
des plaisanteries pas toujours bon goût
évidemment mais ça ça dénote tu es enfin
si vous voulez quelque chose à faire
maintenant
soyons justes dans les monarchies
d'europe du nord norvège suède stockholm
danemark vous avez eu aussi des mélanges
et des gens parlant avec des accents
quelquefois improbable voilà et et nous
on a un empereur c'est napoléon iii qui
parlait avec un accent suisse allemand
alors oui il avait d'ailleurs la
nationalité jeunes des allées
nationalité il avait ce qu'on appelle
les lettres de citoyenneté est ce que
comme il avait vécu beaucoup en exil en
suisse en exil en suisse à arenberg
et c'était assez curieux
alors il ya celui qui va donner le nom
de saxe-cobourg-gotha à la famille
royale anglaise c'est le prince albert
le mari de la reine victoria
la reine victoria on la connaît surtout
vieille mais elle était jeune et elle
était très amoureuse de ce monsieur
salle albert de saxe cobourg gotha le
prince albert qui a laissé d'ailleurs
une un truc sado maso c'est la croix de
saint-albert c'est lié à quoi d'ailleurs
pour ça je sais pas franchement mais
c'est un homme qui a comment dirais-je
compris qu il devait avoir une utilité
s'est trouvé un rôle d'oncle est devenu
le prince consort ça n'a pas été simple
parce que victoria ce petit bout de
femme était un monument d'énergie
d'activité et il a fait beaucoup pour le
développement industriel économique de
l'angleterre fait la grande bretagne à
l'époque puisque ce n'est pas encore le
royaume uni
très très intéressant comme personnage
pas du tout fall au bond
le prince albert aura le titre de prince
consort ce qui sera toujours un sujet
délicat d'être obligé de deux pas trois
pas derrière le il faut savoir que dans
la famille britannique quand une femme
règne le son mari des parois non alors
que quand c'est un homme qui règne si un
jour charles règne à peu sa femme sera
reine oui c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison que la reine elizabeth a voulu
que charles puisque épousé camilla pour
que la situation conjugale du couple en
pratique appelée à régner soit
stabilisée au moment de son décès on y
reviendra
edouard 7 on peut alors d'abord et
victoria est important parce qu'en fait
tout le ses descendants vont être dans
toutes les cours d'europe ses
descendants à elle et au prince albert
qui mourra relativement jeune elle va
être ville va être veuf pendant
pratiquement une quarantaine est
l'araignée très longtemps oui et elle va
soi-même impératrice des zones sans y
aller mais elle va faire une chose que
sa descendante est la b2 n'a pas voulu
faire elle va montrer son deuil au monde
entier nato ria ce qu'ils avaient deux
refusent et on l'a vu tout de suite
après les funérailles du prince philip
elle est apparue un sommet du g7 et à
des diverses manifestations avec des
tenues claire et ses râles de z se fait
plus de bien comme ça se faisait oublier
la vieme ciel et grands deuils ou en
reste elles ont été réglés l'attrait la
durée elle l'a prolongé indéfiniment
mais ce qui est intéressant avec albert
donc c'est que c'est ce côté visionnaire
et parenté avec la belgique avec
beaucoup de familles d'europe qui a eu
des idées pour les expositions
universelles
tout ça c'est bien alors évidemment
victoria cats on pense aujourd'hui à
l'âge de la reine actuelle
95 ans
victoria
c'est un monument qui résistait à tout
et avant 1900
le son fils le futur edouard 7 prince de
galles qui adorait la france et les
français commencent et les folies
bergères effet les bordels absolument
adoré venir dans les cabarets de
montmartre et la police était embêté
parce qu'on savait qu'il voulait se
rendre au cabaret de rodolphe salissent
le chat noir et ont dit aux patrons à la
côte et se soit abstenue vous avez
l'habitude d'insulter vos clients ce
soir c'est le futur roi d'angleterre
harrods jadis ticket sur l'insulté je
vais lui demander des nouvelles de sa
famille il accueille lisant alors mon
seigneur et cette maman victoria
toujours en bonne santé voilà
les questions qu'on a dû poser tellement
au prince charles on va le voir edouard
7 parce que les français en ont gardé un
bon souvenir c'est lui qui va nous
réconcilier définitivement après après
la chaude à cava être l'artisan de
l'entente corps l'entente cordiale et la
fin de l' isolement de l'angleterre
parce que l'angleterre est un immense
empire blessant alliés sont alliées et
aidé on va être les premiers alliés de
l'angleterre of ce que ceux qui la bête
de a rappelé au président mitterrand au
moment de l'inauguration du tunnel sous
la manche donc edouard 7 à un règne et
ses courses et le père de georges e3 de
georges 5 et de georges e 6 ce qui est
d'un mal si vous permettez c'est que
edouard 7 pas été vivant aux mamans de
1914 car je suis sûr qu'il aurait fait
la tournée des monarchies européennes en
dix ans après sarajevo en se calmant se
calme ça va être épouvantable
il a manqué de se perdirent ils sont
tous cousins d'offrir est surtout les
pays qui vont se jeter dans cette guerre
et ils étaient ils étaient très très
amusant le sait par exemple un jour il
est en vacances j'ai au pays basque et à
biarritz et il a nommé un premier
ministre
dans le territoire français ce qui en
principe ne doute ce qui a bien fait mal
pris d'ailleurs ça a été assez mal vu
mais il a posé beaucoup de choses
son fils donc
c'est georges 5 georges 5 son héritier
c'est edouard 8 c'est la photo on en
revient à la photo du départ ce jeune il
était très beau c'était le célibataire
le plus convoité du royaume au fond il
aurait il été fait pour avoir une vie de
playboy alors c'est dommageable à tout
point de vue parce qu'ils avaient été
très courageux pendant la guerre edwards
il avait même pris des risques comme
prague ce prince de galles mal de la
première guerre mondiale instruments et
il avait fait remarquer ce qui était
exact que le traité de versailles était
comme le dira jacques bainville trop dur
dans ce qu'ils avaient de mou et robes
ou lorsqu'il avait deux durs et vu les
origines germaniques de la famille il
pensait qu' il ne fallait pas continué
d'accabler l'allemagne alors évidemment
tout ceci a débordé après une grande
importance et katy s'est mis à avoir de
la sympathie pour hitler c'était tout à
fait différent et en découvrant ce
moment là avec horreur
que le nazisme a de nombreux soutiens en
grande bretagne en tout cas au royaume
uni puisque on peut parler d' royaume
uni avec l'irlande du nord depuis 1922 à
peu près et évidemment sa vie
personnelle et scandaleuse toutes ses
maîtresses sont des femmes mariées ce
pas très original comme dirait sacha
guitry mais là il tombe sur une
professionnelle de la séduction wallis
simpson
qui devait avoir des talents très
spéciaux de près les chroniques et qui
confond la situation d'être la maîtresse
du prochain roi avec une sorte d'
agences où elle jette un oeil sur les
documents secrets elle renvoie ses
papiers avec des rondes verre de whisky
enfin tout ça ne fait pas convenable et
le gouvernement de ce prêt va qu'est
alors c'est très intéressant parce que
la population a tout de suite compris
quand elle a été informée mais elle ne
l'a pas été tout de suite que cette
femme serait une catastrophe et même les
syndicats qui aimait beaucoup le prince
de galles et edward ondine s'il épouse
ne voulons pas de cette comme
rennes les syndicats
il était extrêmement populaire était
très possible et s il est alors c'était
pour la reine actuelle c'était oncle
david qu'ils aient des farces qui est
venu en voisin faisait des charades
faisait des dessins et puis comme l'a
raconté la future elizabeth 2 tout d'un
coup elle a constaté qu'on le voyait
moins et que papa et maman ne met pas le
voir et qu'il y avait sept
cette dame américaine
évidemment les deux isabelle et cette
dame j'aimerais bien qu'on la voit
d'ailleurs parce qu'on a beaucoup de
photos elle est ce qu'elle était si
belle que ça non et je pense qu'alors
elle était moi je veux dire j'ai vu
j'avais 16 ans était au ritz
j'accompagnais mes parents et mon père
guy des cars me dis tiens regarde cette
femme regarde cette femme qui a fait
s'écrouler d'un monarchie britannique
j'avais l'impression de voir franchement
paix à son âme un serpent était
complexée petit jalouse et son on
sentait qu'elle en voulait à la terre
entière parce que avec ce qui s'est
passé
n'est jamais devenu altesse royale que
ce que hitler s'est empressé de faire et
de l'appeler pour l'impasse et elle le
dominer sans doute par l'essence
sexuellement elle avait une réputation
très très établi à ce sujet elle le
traitait de crétin je pense que c'était
un faible un homme charmant mais pas
fait pour avoir une vision
courageuse de travail en permanence il
s'amusait beaucoup et ça a été donc
désinstalleur il faut bien le dire que
dans l'histoire britannique une
application c'était quelque chose qui
n'existait pas s'il ya un mot
indications de son plein gré de son
plein gré s'il ya un mot aujourd'hui qui
est le cauchemar pour la reine elizabeth
ii se serait de parler d' abdication
elle pour à mon avis elle sera rennes
jusqu'au bout elle mourra rennes voilà
ne serait ce que parce que la famille ou
et s'est dressé contre l'indication de
deux des douars 8000 et la lui a fait
payer toute sa vie parce que lui il
imagine il aurait aimé revenir en
angleterre en tant qu altesse royale
vivre de ses privilèges
avec sa femme ils ont dit non alors ils
l'ont interdit de revenir intéressant
dans en sautant les générations comme on
parle de harry et mégane aujourd'hui
forcément les britanniques ne peuvent
pas éviter à certains parallèles avec
une autre américaine
au talent intimes a priori évident et
qui
emmène harry aux états-unis au canada et
que c'était grave l'abandon de poste et
wallis avait fait une longue croisière
dont les britanniques n'ont jamais
entendu parler parce que la presse a été
muselée à ce moment là mais tous les
journaux européens en parlait donc en
fait c'était un noceur intelligent mais
nos soeurs il parlait des doigts 8
ladouari les doigts 8 à des gens pensent
et ma chute j'ai l'impression que tenait
bien alors ils donnaient pas
l'impression d'être très intelligent
mais il y avait du bon sens mais
beaucoup une grande
flemme une grande paresse
donc l'art de faire des cocktails son
élégance 2013 et légal ça évidemment
c'était très important un grand danseur
enfin tout ça ne suffisait pas à ce qui
est intéressant de rappeler c'est que
churchill a soutenu un peu cette idylle
et on le lui a reproché après parce que
clan qu'il disait moi je tort mais je
suis un romantique
et et son frère donc georges 6 qui
hérite du trône et c'est alors que il
n'en voulez pas vous avez expliqué
pourquoi oui va lui donner lui conférer
le titre de duc de windsor de du fléau
le mot windsor le mot ou une soeur qui
revient et c'est à windsor que
edward 8 à 10 quais de lui salon du
château de windsor donc ce nom était
vraiment bien
ancrée dans la mythologie britannique
beth a été épouvantable pour la famille
la honte cette abdication alors
on impose ce qu'il a aucun sens du
devoir et ses et c'est ce qu'on va se
sentir après dans la monarchie
britannique ici et là l'absence de sens
du devoir que ces 6es lisabeth elle sens
du devoir ces bâtis là-dessus non
l'impression que c'est la dernière c'est
la seule de l'impression que le sens du
devoir déjà pour le prince philippe
s'est déjà limite mais alors pour les
autres l'idée est déjà pour lui c'était
passé il faut il faut mélanger parce que
philippe ne pouvait pas être roi était
toujours depuis
l'annnonce de la mort de georges 6 en
1952 l'écuyer à la descente de l'avion
lui a dit deux pas derrière donc il va
dire mais je n'existe pas et va se
battre justement de son devoir c'était
de ne pas exister justement mais il a
fini par réussir à exister par ses
plaisanteries pas toujours de très bon
goût et en faisant un énorme travail je
dirais associatif et caritatif que qui
ne faut pas oublier et il finira vers la
fin de sa vie en disant je suis le
champion du monde de l'inauguration des
plaques commémoratives
il avait fait beaucoup de choses alors
c'est tout à fait différent pour charles
jean charles est prêt à être roi depuis
qu'il a été intronisé prince de galles
il est prêt à prendre la relève dès que
le premier ministre sur avis médical
ayant constaté le décès de la souveraine
voilà le laverty on sait qu'il ya un nom
de code la reine a été furieuse que
selon son nom de code soit divulguée il
ya environ trois semaines il y en a
forcément un nouveau jaser renvoie le
nom de code c'est elle en donne dans
london bridge falling down c'est
toujours très souvent c'est autour d'un
monument ou d'un endroit très célèbre
dans l'autre parce qu' elle c'est qu'on
considère toujours cette devise je peux
si elle est exacte d'ailleurs never
explain never complain ou et ne jamais
s'expliquer ne jamais se plaindre et on
a l'impression que elisabeth l'a
toujours respecté mais qu'elle est les
seuls même philippe ces bruits plein
dans une interview aux états unis restée
célèbre qu'il n'avait pas assez d'argent
qu'ils avaient été obligés de vendre un
yacht ou se sont plaint constamment le
prince charles en impression qui ne fait
que se plaindre les dj enfin la presse
indienne alors il faut pas mélanger
parce que maintenant charles ne se
plaint plus il est prêt parce que quand
même sa mère a 95 ans il est
suit le développement des messages des
entretiens avec le premier ministre
parce que la reine doit être capable
d'étudier les dossiers des projets de
dire est ce que vous êtes sûr que c'est
la bonne décision et je veux en savoir
plus là dessus la reine continue de
travailler beaucoup c'est une très très
grande travailleuse on dit à londres que
quand on voit la fenêtre de sa chambre
encore à lumière minuit cclat rennes est
encore plongée dans ces dossiers c'est
une femme très sérieuse à ce point de
vue là ce que n'était pas sa soeur
margaret enfin celle problème
on va en parler bien que vend pas les
mets charles est prêt alors il peut y
avoir une régence si la reine avait une
incapacité des difficultés de tous
ordres il pourrait y avoir une régence
c'est possible je pense que je dis bien
l'implication est un tel cauchemar parce
qu'elle a vu ses parents souffrir elle a
vu la population britannique avoir honte
de cette situation c'est épouvantable
elle avait elle avait 10 ans 11 ans
quand c'est arrivé elle a vu le
changement de dates mosphere dans la
famille ce qui se passait c'est normal
repoussé alors que c'est l'honneur
d'être roi mais un tel pays puisque ce
qu'on veut plus et la femme qu'on aime
et absolue elle problème c'est que
wallis simpson avait une réputation
tellement sulfureuse que évidemment si
ç'avait été a priori une histoire
d'amour d'établi mais là on sentait une
américaine très intéressée qu'elle était
divorcée deux fois de façon l'église
anglicane n'aurait jamais accepté dans
at-on fait on fait une pause et on y
revient tout de suite après jour des cas
[Musique]
on continue cette émission avec jean des
cars qui publie la saga des windsor chez
perrin l'histoire de cette famille
allemande d'origine qui a changé de nom
en 1917 en pleine première guerre
mondiale pour se rebaptiser windsor qui
s'appelait saxe cobourg gotha comme les
bombardiers allemands qui étaient en
train de massacrer la population
londonienne
c'est winsor qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
la firme
ses récents à ce sobriquet oui c'est
peut-être le prince philip qui la
trouvaient on n'en est pas sûr oui mais
sa volée ça dénote aussi un esprit de
solidarité c'est à dire qu' il ya des
affaires qu'on règle en famille en privé
on étale pas tout ouais c'est ça je
professe que ceux qui ont lu jon gries
âmes la firme s'est en plus quand on
règle les affaires en famille on en
supprime quelques-uns voilà
elizabeth 2 donc alors l on la connaît
tellement bien mais est ce qu'on la
connaît vraiment reprendre la série vous
avez peut-être vu la série sur netflix
nous a appris à voir elizabeth 2 d'une
autre manière au fond comme quelqu'un de
beaucoup plus romanesque qu'on ne le
croyait oui alors sur la série de crâne
il faut déjà remarqué de libéralisme de
la famille royale qui laisse écrire ils
ont pas vraiment le choix et tournai non
mais enfin avec des scènes d'intimité
assez poussée alors au début c'était
très exact me semble-t-il là il ya
quelques libertés qui ont été prises
comme le dit mon confrère la butte
l'essai et de maman est-ce que ça s'est
vraiment passé ainsi comme ça on ne sait
pas mais ça fait rêver ça n'est pas
exactement une leçon d'histoire mais
c'est une leçon d'intimité on entre dans
l'intimité de la plus célèbre monarchie
du monde à pourquoi est elle célèbre ça
c'est très important
en 1953 il zabeth 2 avec un modernisme
étonnant des sites que sont sacrés son
couronnement os mister seront télévisées
alors la télévision est à ses débuts
churchill contre en disant je ne vois
pas pourquoi les caméras de la bbc
et mieux que moi non et la reine dit je
veux que les gens qui sont très
éloignées qui sont très loin dans des
petits villages
soient aussi invités à westminster et à
partir de ce moment là et moi je m'en
souviens j'avais une dizaine d'années je
l' ai vu c'est un spectacle et ce
spectacle si je puis dire continu
c'est-à-dire qu'elle isabey de est
devenue une reine de l'image
le monde entier un pu être témoin et
suit alors les mariages les enterrements
tous les événements royaux etc c'est la
seule à ce point parce que les
monarchies scandinaves sont c'est pas la
même histoire c'est pas la même
dimension monsieur bongo fille discrète
toutefois intéressante à la reine
margrethe de danemark règne depuis plus
de 50 ans est pas inintéressant à des
rares pays d'europe avec laquelle la
france n'a jamais été en guerre
enfin elizabeth 2 et dans le paysage
depuis toujours avec
ses ailes à ses habilleuse elle a ses
habitudes
je veux dire c'est une femme très
organisé très consciencieuse qui
travaillent il faut le savoir qui s'est
très bien entendu avec des premiers
ministres travaillistes notamment par
exemple avec harold wilson on sait
qu'avec madame thatcher c'était un
cauchemar parce que madame thatcher se
prenait pour l'état elle n'était si
j'ose dire que le gouvernement et
elizabeth 2 ans née à son 16e 17e
premier ministre du royaume-uni 160 dans
le monde du commonwealth bank avec des
états qui vont devenir des républiques
ou qui ne vaut plus la reconnaître ce
sera là la fin d'une époque
mais elle a eu un courage extraordinaire
dans les années 60 elle s'oppose au
gouvernement
qu'il a qui veulent empêcher d'aller
dans un pays africain au ghana
l'ancienne gold coast dont le président
est devenu un marxiste est un personnage
qui ne rêve que de moscou et de ses
idées elle y va pourquoi pas ce qu'elle
avait promis de lui faire une visite et
elle aime tenir ses engagements donc
elle y va et on a sept cents seulement
inouïe où ce marxiste à fond a mis un
smoking et danse avec la reine et la
traite de rennes la plus socialiste du
monde de l'art elle a vu comme ça en
ethiopie le négus parce qu'elle lui
avait promis et c'est dans son caractère
et c'est pour ça que coptes par exemple
mégane qu'elle a envoyé en mission avec
un riz en afrique au nom du commonwealth
pour faire le point et c est que megan a
considéré que c'était un hochet c'était
une insulte pour la reine qui disait je
me dévoue depuis des années je
m'intéresse à ces gens j'essaie de
comprendre leurs problèmes je crois
qu'il faut bien avoir en tête ce 21
avril 1947 quand la princesse elizabeth
qui n'est pas encore mariée qui est au
cap en afrique du sud avec ses parents
déjà très très amoureuse on le sait de
philippe val épouse et quelques mois
plus tard dit que ma vie soit longue ou
courte je serai au service de la nation
c'est donc une femme de devoir s'il
n'empêche pas d'être drôle de faire des
blagues de plaisanter
c'est pas toujours visibles justement ce
sac est subtile je veux dire le monde
avec elizabeth 2 on est habitué à la
voir donc depuis 1953 partout et avouer
que l'humour qu'elle a eue en se mettant
pour une fois en scène en jouant son
premier rôle pour les jeux olympiques de
1992 avec james bond pendant une minute
dix c'est tout de même énorme ce n'est
pas elle qui saute en parachute non
c'est bien elle qui l'aurait syrie veut
régler ce cas d'heures d'ailleurs l'un
de ces cascadeurs est mort trois mois
plus tard mais je veux dire il ya une
une autodérision formidable après la
mort du prince philippe l'a accueilli
donc en cornouaille des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement au jet set et elle dit
au moment de la photo officielle est-ce
que nous sommes censés nous amuser vous
qu'elle a fait éclater de rire tout le
monde elle était officiellement en deuil
mais elle a sûrement beaucoup d'humour
je pense que la vie avec elle doit être
profondément ennuyeuse mais je parle de
la vie privée la vie intime
je suis mal placé pour en parler c'est
une femme de devoir qui parle un
français absolument délicieux qu'elle a
un prix avec une institutrice d'origine
belge et moi je me souviens de ses
visites en france auprès de tous les
présidents étaient absolument délicieux
surtout quand elle disait à l'elysée
vive la différence
quand quand elle épouse
les philippe seta mode battle aussi ont
changé de nom c'est lé battenberg
d'automne berne allemande ailleurs deux
de ses soeurs ont épousé des nazis mais
ce qu'ils n'entrent a vertement reproché
oui et les soeurs de philippe justement
ne sont pas invités invité au mariage ce
sera bon mais la question se pose est-ce
que est ce que la famille va s'appeler
marne baptême ou une sorte comme la
famille s'était appelé alors
saxe-cobourg-gotha parce que albert le
mari de victoria s'appelait et lui il
n'y aura pas droit voilà il y a eu de
grandes discussions
philippe était furieux il faut dire que
son oncle l'amiral bateau normand breton
avait fait une petite gaffe à 10 ans
maintenant la maison bamba tonnes règne
à windsor et à londres et donc le prince
philippe avec une notion de biologie
assez limité dit je ne suis qu'une
maudite amibes devant les admins n'ont
pas besoin de s'accoupler pour faire des
enfants ils étaient vexés et il faudra
que la reine impose au gouvernement
le fait qu' il puisse avoir son nom et
que les enfants s'appelleront dorénavant
man battle windsor donc mélangeant des
deux ça a été grande bataille d'identité
la reine y est très sensible alors il ya
la princesse margaret aujourd'hui bien
oublié mais qui a beaucoup peu distrait
les gazettes pendant pendant des
destinations miller c'est que la
première elle aussi voulait épouser un
homme disait alors qu'ils n'étaient même
pas encore divorcé lui il faut il faut
quand même voir que c'est encore le
résultat de l'image le jour du
couronnement d'elizabeth ii
ce 2 juin 1953 la reine est partie dans
son carrosse vers buckingham palace et
sa soeur margaret qu'elle aime beaucoup
personnellement qui est un peu le clown
de la famille qui s'amusent qui chante
le piano quitté très jeune il peut fort
très joli et là elle attend sa voiture
il y à un officier qui est à côté d'elle
et tout d'un coup une caméra sur pau un
geste elle et poussettes l'épaule de cet
officier qui a quelques plumes
c'est le des gestes conjugale geste
conjugale est donc alors s'aperçoit que
cet homme est un héros de la bataille
d'angleterre de la royal air force
pilote extraordinaire bon ils étaient
deux camps du roi mais des têtes en
instance de divorce etc nous sommes dans
un royaume uni exemple héroïque mais
exemple où les restrictions sont telles
que pour rien que pour son mariage en 47
elisabeth a dû demander des coûts de pau
à ses copines pour avoir du tissu il
faut bien comprendre que le le
l'héroïsme était au prix de une absence
de confort total à tout point de vue
donc
margaret je pense qu'il faut bien dire
les choses ce n'est pas la reine qui lui
a causé des ennuis c'est le gouvernement
qui a dit et légumes n'ont pas de site
je ne voulons pas d'une princesse qui
boit trop qui va dans les boîtes de nuit
qui ferait qui fréquent des des gens pas
très convenable et lui accorder une
liste civile ça a été une grande douleur
pour elisabeth parce qu'elle était très
copines des deux soeurs on l'a vu en
photo mais j'aimerais bien qu'on la voit
pas ce qu'est la très jolie enfants très
jeune et très jolie magath je reviendrai
très jolie ou la draille toutes les deux
et elle était dans toutes les deux au
jubilé de leur grand père paternel
georges 5 elles ont commencé à faire des
dessins vous avez à peu près 10 ans et
voilà dont elle était très lié cette
grande douleur pour est devenue la
princesse triste d'en inscrire sa
blondeur triste elle va elle va être
dans cette lignée après après edouard 8
oui avant le prince charles de cette
saison pour contrarier les amours et
c'est à dire que on découvre tout d'un
coup que ces personnes là sont des êtres
humains avec des battements de coeur
avec des faiblesses avec des erreurs
avec des grands amours avec des patients
contrarier ou la politique et la
diplomatie ce sens mal ça n'est pas
toujours facile et notamment d'être en
représentation c'est infernal soir et
puis surtout de ne servir à rien parce
que font alors je vais je me bats
elizabeth ii dans un mail les autres ne
servent à rien le prince charles ne sert
à rien depuis qu'il est né
de se dire qu'il sera le prochain ben
fort mais il est prêt ce qui n'est pas
simple d'un homme charmant il m'a reçue
à buckingham palace il a beaucoup
d'humour
violet pour le fil enfantine et on a
nous est arrivé quelque chose qui est
absolument grotesque et digne de laurel
et hardy c'est à dire que le tout d'un
coup les appareils photos du photographe
plus les balles car les projecteurs plus
rien ne marche j'ai envie de l'étrangler
dans la tour de londres et quand je
m'aperçois que mon magnétophone ne
marche plus fait des confettis ni aussi
donc le prince de galles c'était en 82
peu de temps avant son mariage avec dana
me dit vous avez un problème se dégager
mon seigneur c'est à la fois à un cours
et waterloo fait rire je lui dis mais on
va peut-être sauvé une photo d'après ce
qu'on me dit et caetera et me dit ah
alors comme aurait dit le roi françois
1er après pavie tout est perdu fors
l'honneur je me sens très gentil et on a
pu sauver deux blocs non charles est un
homme qui travaille beaucoup
contrairement à ce qu'on pense qui est
prêt en permanence alors avec évidemment
l'angoissent maintenant le temps passe
des événements
se précipite son destin peut se préciser
mais il est parfaitement au courant en
permanence c'est sa fonction bien sûr ça
ne se voit pas mais c'est réel il va
épouser la princesse diana alors dieu
sait si on a écrit on a fait des films
alors sur cette affaire vous justement
je vais qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous et surtout de la princesse diana
canadien paix à son âme mais elle était
je cite les mots du comte spencer son
frère à ses obsèques elle était perverse
c'est son frère
étant lui même quand même je savais très
bien que charles avait une passion avec
camilla belle s'est mis dans la tête de
faire briser cette union y arriver elle
a échoué et on connaît la suite c'est
vraiment épouvantable
moi je me souviens cote donné
rendez-vous à des journalistes et puis
deux jours après quelques journalistes
arrivés en pensant avoir à scoops comme
on dit jamais je vous ai pas appelé et
c'était quand même terrible alors paix à
son âme mais n'était pas aussi angélique
que cela il y en a vu dans l'interview à
la bbc etc elle a dit des choses
terribles alors ils ont dû être très
malheureux tous c'est assez infernal
voilà ce qui m'inquiète voyez vous c'est
quand je vois harry et mégane je trouve
malsain même si c'est humain que harry
vive si je puis dire avec une sorte de
fantôme de sa maman de diana est-ce que
vous pensez que megan imite baena
écouter quand elle a dit oui diana a été
maltraité et cetera comme moi et cetera
avec les bijoux qu'elle porte je trouve
que le la simulation me paraît pas très
saine oui enfin on pourrait se dire on
en revient toujours à never explain
never complet il n'y à partir du moment
où il s'explique et 8 se plaignent ils
sont de toute façon insupportable
absolument ils ne vivent que eux
justement de des subsides publics fermés
a pu démarrer donc mais c'est une image
vous savez la monarchie britannique
coûte moins cher que la république
française on sait ce qu'on dit oui
fonctionnement fonctionnement tous les
calculs ont été faits mais alors
évidemment on ne veut pas déçu par le
spectacle et là on a vu la reine donc
personne n'oubliera je le redis cette
image la reine veuve et cetera qui
essayent de d'effacer son veuvage je ne
sais pas si on la reverra à cheval sa
grande passion que son grand-père plan
de 5 lui avais absolument inculquer mais
on l'a vu il ya trois semaines un mois
conduire sa jaguar dans le parc de
windsor avait pas trop de danger elle
ira jusqu'au bout quant à camilia
qui deviendra donc reine d'angleterre
camilla parker bowles quand elle était
encore marié à son mari
comment la voile et les anglais parce
que c'est à la fois la briseuse de
ménage celle qui a rendu la vie
impossible à diana que tout le monde
adore oui mais le temps est passé
actuellement le couple fait des voyages
important ils reviennent de jordanie
elle se fait mieux connaître et je crois
que
on voit très bien qu'il s'entend très
bien d'ailleurs l'église protestante a
été heureux si je puis dire de célébrer
ce mariage sans on n'a pas vu de la
cérémonie civile et la reine a donné son
accord je répète il fallait que son fils
soit bien installé dans sa vie
personnelle le jour où elle
disparaîtrait
depuis william a épousé
kate middleton qu'on appelle kate mais
qui en réalité s'appelle catherine avait
classé ce que vous rappelez et leur
mariage a été évidemment un grand
spectacle en lui il existe et ça a été
aussi la façon dont après le cauchemar
diana la reine et l'ensemble a pu
remonter dans l'opinion parce que
l'opinion était ce qu'il épousait une
roturière absolument mais c'est la
première fois qu'une future reine
possible du royaume uni viendra de la
bourgeoisie moyenne et le charme de deux
quêtes sont alençon éclats ont fait
beaucoup pour la restauration du
prestige la monarchie et la reine était
tellement contente que le soir du
mariage de kate et william n'a autorisé
à ce qu'on ouvre le quatrième étage de
buckingham palace pour en faire une
boîte de nuit était très bon si oui
c'est elle c'est vrai que kate à al
étoffe la lure et cetera voilà elle est
si je puis dire déjà dans le rôle entre
guy louis pion aussi qu'elle ne posera
pas de problème dans la priory llr
équilibré vous voulez plein de problèmes
de de megan
séquelles dans le fond elle en veut à
tout le monde en permanence alors nous
savons sa vie compliquée difficile et
cetera mais les accusations qu'elle a
lancée tout ça preuve et l'état l'âge
avis public ça c'est une chose que la
reine était stoppé leur dire parce
qu'elle a vécu elle le cauchemar j'y
reviens de l'application de son oncle l
étalage des détails les plus sordides
qu'elles avaient eux aussi avec diana et
charles absolue quand même rentable ah
oui absolue
donc
reste chez meghan markle il ya la fois
de wallis simpson et de la princesse
diana au fond il ya des deux heures du
mans c'est donc il ya une comédienne qui
joue un peu le rôle d'un fantôme de
diana
c'est je trouve que c'est très délicat
c'est un jeu très subtil et harry me
semble et qui est pas réputé non plus
pour être dans l'urgence extraordinaire
non et surtout il faut le dire ils ont
quitté le royaume uni au moment de la
pandémie et au moment où on avait les
premières alertes de santé sur le prince
philip et ne pas être à noël à
sandringham rompre les traditions les
usages c'est détestable pour la reine il
ya quelque chose de très important chez
la reine dans son discours de noël qui
est le seul qu'elle écrive elle-même moi
dit ce qu'elle veut il faut voir les
portraits qu'elle a sur son bureau
autour d'elle il y en a qui
disparaissent il ya là qu'on voit en
permanence philippe son père georges 6
et cetera mais la dernière fois on a vu
qu'il en manquait ça veut dire qu'elle a
été déçu après avoir fait tout ce
qu'elle pouvait le prince andrew a
transformé en traité sur la table parce
qu'on sait bien faire et nine alors là
c'est effrayant parce que certains
scandales sexuels en tout
ce qui est pire en dessous et pourquoi
est ce pire pour la reine parce que
c'était son enfant favori c'était
l'enfant la réconciliation après une
grave crise avec philippe quand il était
parti faire un tour du monde jusqu'aux
jeux olympiques en australie et le
prince andrew qui avait déjà été déchu
par son mariage avec une certaine sarah
ferguson oui ça qui n'est pas un modèle
ça fait un petit peu désordre et si ce
que c'est la reine qui détestent alors
elle est pas maniaque elle est organisée
lé temps donné
abete de elle n'aime pas qu'on fasse
n'importe quoi on peut avoir de l'humour
on peut faire des petites blagues
philippe n'arrêtait pas d'en faire mais
dans une certaine limite surtout pas de
pas de mauvais goût mais on a du mal à
imaginer et à chaque fois que les les
séries ou les films je pense notamment
aux films spencer qui vient de sortir
oui dont diana est l'héroïne à chaque
fois qu'on les voit ensemble ça à
sandringham notamment dans spencer au
moment de noël on se dit mais qu'est ce
qu'ils s'ennuient qu'est-ce qui s'ennuie
on se demande s'ils se détestent pas
tous les uns les autres en plus je ne
pense pas mais d'ailleurs n'avait
handicap terrible ce n'est pas de sa
faute qu'elle détestait la campagne
alors ne pas aimer la campagne et faire
partie de la famille royale britannique
ça c'est un cauchemar même chose pour
madame thatcher qui était arrivé à
balmoral avec des chaudes des petits
chaussures et on le voit dans ce coin
c'est vrai voilà donc au lieu d'avoir
une bonne paire de bottes dans un
terrain humide ne pas aimer la campagne
ne pas aimer les chiens les chevaux et
cetera
ça c'est un mauvais point un mauvais
départ mais et william alors dont les
bottes les britanniques attendent oui
visiblement qui se succède à son père
même absolument où il yad'abord a
patiemment le règne de champ mais ils
attendent le règne de william bassil a
frappé chez william hill était très beau
quand il était jeune on l'a vu et tout à
coup il s'est dégarni à une vitesse à la
même vitesse que le prince albert de
monaco et sa basse et ce sur le dga de
la tente sans doute par exemple on se
fait des cheveux puis par la voyez il a
une belle chevelure l'image d'après on
va le voir il en a plus oui
bah oui et albert ça a été ça aussi
c'est peut-être ça oui on a la pression
va se beaucoup sous les crânes au fond
on a l'impression que ce destin qui est
le leur depuis qu'ils sont nés de
succéder à leur père
on a l'impression que ça laisse aller
c'est les terrorise ses terrorisant
parce que c'est en face à fait des nra
l'inside fait rien parce que plus le
temps passe plus c'est probable où ça se
rapproche donc c'est un coup de
téléphone un messages codés cryptés ce
que vous voulez
qu'est qu'on redoute donc il faut être
prêt en attendant mais en même temps
nous pète décision à prendre ils se
contentent d'être au courant de
symboliser oui mais avec nomade poupe de
l'affluence la reine a eu énormément
d'influx ans elle a insisté sur beaucoup
de dossiers et elle a accompagné les
changements de moeurs d'une façon
fantastique le swinging london des
années 60 elle en est je dirais la
grande prêtresse avec la mini jupe marie
compte avec les beatles qu'elle va donc
lancer vraiment qu'elle y est pour
quelque chose ah oui parce qu'elle a
adoré oui ils vont la lui dédier une
chanson majesty ils ont adoré la la
reine qui a beaucoup beaucoup d'humour
mais entre l'humour et de mauvais goût
il ya une nuance près ça mais en fait je
me dis est ce qu'on en fait pas une
montagne à partir du moment où
effectivement au fonds de se glisser
dans la peau du roi même si j'imagine
bien que ce n'est rien d'aisé un mais
mais au fond c'est quand même une
responsabilité très limité oui je ne
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous
parce que c'est une responsabilité de
l'image ça peut faire beaucoup de dégâts
et ça en a fait on le sait et je dis
bien parce que l'image est entrée par
pressentiment avec la volonté des
diabètes 2 c'est ce ça donc on voit tout
temps que tout peut se savoir sa terre
prêté on est au courant de tout il ya
des monarchies dans le monde qui sont
très secrète
au moyen-orient où on ne voit rien ou ne
sais pas ce qui se passe et cetera les
monarchies scandinaves sont très
discrètes aussi dans le spectacle est
autour de la couronne britannique
il ya là qu on l'a oublié en france mais
ils ont fait leur révolution les anglais
même siècle avant nous ils ont eux aussi
couper la tête de l'eau roi oui c'était
jacques premier ils ont regardé un très
mauvais souvenir parce que ça a donné
une dictature derrière
semblable à la terreur d'ailleurs
révolutionnaire française donc c'est ce
que rappelait souvent là nous savons ce
qu'est une révolution
nous l'avons vu et c'est à cromwell et
compagnie c'est c'est un exemple si vous
voulez le monde au moment où je vous
parle le monde sans y la bête sera un
monde différent parce qu'en plus pensons
au nombre de gens de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qu'elle a rencontré qu'elle
a connue et c'est pour ça qu'on a ce
paradoxe moi qui m'a toujours intéressé
c'est la femme la plus célèbre du monde
d'une certaine façon est la moins connue
en même temps par sa discrétion par sa
vie et on sait que d'où le succès de ce
corps voilà d'où la section tv awards et
qui donne l'impression aux gens de
pouvoir percer enfin le plafond de verre
est d'être dans l'intimité d'un ponte
des secrets ouais et vous n'avez jamais
rencontré l je les ai vu d'assez près et
donc c'est charles qui m'a reçue à
buckingham dans ses aventures cocasses
tout à fait charmant y avait un
personnage passionnant leur mamba tonnes
il aidait il avait une qualité
formidable savait faire des compliments
aux femmes quand il était en france
disait madame lorsqu on vous voit on
sait qu'on est en france c'était quand
même quelqu'un qui avait beaucoup
d'alluré qui était on disait que sa
femme l'avait trompé avec nehru oui
c'est sûr qu'il était vice roi des indes
c'est vrai oui absolument il a écrit
lui-même c'est une tragédie ben des
choses qui arrivent comment les civils
et les vingt quand on connaît le racisme
des anglais oui oui et en même temps il
ya des choses extraordinaires parce qu'à
son mariage
il y la bête a reçu
de gandhi elle a reçu des cadeaux
extraordinaires qui ont dérangé tout le
monde mais elles étaient sensibles aux
attentions des gens encore une fois ce
personnage qui s'est tellement de choses
qui avaient emmagasiné tellement de
dossiers et qui n'a pas eu des moments
faciles si on se replace en 1956 c'est
l'époque de l'expédition de suez et de
son fiasco la reine a signé la
mobilisation de l'état major et des
troupes qui vont partir pour défendre le
canal de suez que l'inter veut
nationaliser et on sait que c'est très
très mal passé elle était furieuse parce
qu'elle a dit les renseignements
militaires qu'on m'a donnée n'était pas
exacte donc c'est assez dur qu'est-ce
qu'elle ait dû dire au moment de l'irak
voilà le genre de choses et donc si vous
voulez il ya tellement de choses le fait
que par exemple il ya cinq ans elle qui
passe pour très éloigné de la mode qui a
toujours la même allure si je puis dire
les couleurs du chapeau mais c'est très
étudiée a enfin assister à un défilé de
mode à côté d'un à winter la papesse de
la mode américaine des magazines
spécialisés
elle s'adapte et elle était descendue à
150 m dans le sous sol londonien pour
inaugurer les travaux d'une ligne de
métro
prolongée qui s'appellera l'aï la bête
lines dont elle ne verra peut-être pas
la mise en service mais elle elle est
complètement dans la vie enfin jusqu'à
une période récente et je crois pouvoir
dire qu'il continue à travailler à fond
ce dossier la saga des windsor ça vient
de paraître aux éditions perrin merci
jean des cars dois remercier toute cette
émission avec nous merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
oui